[Applause]
guys if you ever put this together
already maybe you're listening online
but if you're watching the video I have
to be honest with you because I've
always been honest with our audience and
I feel like that connectivity that we
have is based on trust and truth we
don't actually have the tiger King here
I know you guys were fourth I know you
were fooled for a second pretty
convincing right it was convincing when
I came in and left earlobe was twice the
size we stopped the whole interview he
believed dude I don't even want to tell
people what he was using as you know
this little key key rings yeah listen to
the electoral thing that we were talking
about the other day that's how you get
that that's how you get the illness
that's the 5g that's the 5g so we
actually have mark Gagnon in the
building he's joining us here and so
it's not the tire king but I do want to
open this up for an interesting tire
King discussion because I was absolutely
fascinated by the doctor if you finish
the doctor yes okay I'll have you come
close to finishing just about now
anybody who hasn't finished the caught
the documentary there's nothing that is
ruined by us talking about this tell you
the ending at the beginning yeah the
documentary is not about the ending the
documentary is about the absolute
craziness it transpires over eight
episode of seven episodes then seven
episodes of this show if you haven't
watched it you can stop this podcast
right now and go watch it I would not be
offended at all you'll come right back
to it because you want to have a
conversation about this there's some
fascinating characters about it if you
don't know what's going on you will
within a day everybody's texting their
friends
I don't think Netflix could have picked
a more perfect time to drop this yeah
because right now we want a fantastical
form of distraction and you cannot
believe what this is is real you cannot
believe it you know I also think it's
brilliant you know my main gripe with it
was what it's too long
but if you're quarantined you got
nothing better to do it was too long
I loved that for a second because I I
was it might be a personal thing where I
don't like to see it at all no I saw his
face when you said did you finish it at
all he goes I came close and then I just
kind of smirked at him go like I know he
didn't enjoy it maybe why people enjoy
it more something I don't know but I
don't like making a murderer do this how
many black people were in the
documentary there was one yeah which one
it was a guy that was gonna vote for
Tiger cake and I think da cantle had a
black girl or like brown girl was
something she was some kinda dark girl
there's a dark let's start to look
darker when there's none of them around
but I just don't making a murderer was
another like seven part thing that I
just quit on and it was already two
maybe it's a white thing it might
because I was just like I'm gonna do
this cuz we're talking about it it's the
number one show on Netflix right now
literally number one in America let's
talk about it let's finish it and it
wasn't awful yeah but I had to fight to
get through it
are you fight hitting it through this
[ __ ] this is optimal I was sad when it
finished optimal white okay go on this
tall you have white guys playing with
guns and animals that can kill them
yes and then you have women or white
women complaining about [ __ ] that has
nothing to do with them like for example
this [ __ ] who's complaining about this
what other guys doing with [ __ ] do
with the rescue she's just sad that she
couldn't be the tiger [ __ ] in the
beginning cuz she just didn't have that
game so I was like oh now my thing is
gonna be rescuing Tigers instead of
trying to Sara Lee agree with that but
continue your point but this is just
optimal optimal whiteness because it's
just like white people white boy like at
its most PPK boy fun its death-defying
[ __ ] their gang about [ __ ] that has
nothing to do guns animals and [ __ ]
each other Sun peak whiteboard you go on
black Twitter right now we're looking at
this [ __ ] like yeah what can I just say
something
how's disgusting yeah I I was so not a
judgmental
I was so mad that this was something we
had to walk I'm trying to say [ __ ] I
was trying to stay up with his [ __ ]
like that I was like I can't believe
drew is this engaging this [ __ ]
I love my people I love my people I love
my color bro it is the coppers walk
cannot disagree with you more I think
it's the best thing it's been on TV and
listeners listen no that's what's fire
to XY's fire bro you don't think the
bachelor what do you like remember I've
never watched badger what I've never
start I'll tell you well you missing out
so let me explain why it's so [ __ ]
amazing because it's wrestling but real
doc antal is a wrestling character okay
the tiger King is a wrestling character
Carroll to a certain extent is a
wrestling character all these people are
extreme versions of human beings that
you don't get to see like you see a
wildlife [ __ ] every once in a while
like when your friends really likes
animals or something like Whitney
Cummings loves animals right and like we
talk about animals even Whitney don't
you like cats but Whitney legs am Yeah
right and like you talk to them you
tease them etc but you never get to
fully experience the extremes of this
right
a tiger trainer we've heard of sick
three Android and these [ __ ]
but we're not talking about someone who
owns 200 [ __ ] tires who it costs
$10,000 a month to feed them they don't
have $10,000 so they're getting the
Walmart food that falls off the back of
the truck to feed them and the employees
are also eating the same food the Tigers
are eating like [ __ ] is so mind boggling
about this documentary at white trash
absolutely that's what I think that
minorities would like it because you get
to see white people you can feel better
than Maury say again just turn on Maury
this is boring with Tigers like Maury
with Tigers or peeping out like a [ __ ]
so that's life that's it population
that's it
I think that minors are too homophobic
to appreciate the greatness in this
characters but what I loved about this
is it showed it like to be honest it
showed a side of southerners and I think
they tried to lean into this but like
there's always this idea of southerners
like they're like you know dling dling
Ling Bing I'm spitting on like a
spitting out my [ __ ]
I don't care about anything but my
freedoms one of your freedoms is you get
to do whatever you want with your time
and I think that this show kind of
demonstrated that these hillbilly ass
Hicks southerners who are supposedly
hanging black people from trees and
beating the [ __ ] out of and murdering
gay people not only were they okay with
him being gay they actually were willing
to vote for him for governor he came in
third in the race just because he didn't
give a [ __ ] and he said what was on his
mind and I really think that there's
this fraction that's not even that small
fraction of southerners that we've been
told in New York in California that
they're just super racist they hate
everybody that's not Christian this that
there but they were like okay he's gay
but as long as you do that [ __ ] at your
house and I don't got to see it I don't
give a [ __ ] hmm and they all went to his
[ __ ] Thanksgiving they all went to
his park they took their kids to his
park they knew he was gay the whole time
and I thought it was this really
interesting observation of ballet
southerners where you saw even those
like the dudes that he was gay with they
weren't gay they were addicted to meth
right yeah and they were exploited but
you really saw the exploitation happen
on all on all levels you know what this
show is what it is white-trash Game of
Thrones [ __ ] tape that's what it is
it is white-trash Game of Thrones this
Carol [ __ ] is Cersei Oh Jeff is
Littlefinger
oh gosh with some hot [ __ ] takes
today his name the guy that snitched on
the fifth to the feds
that's Varys yeah I do the right thing
look like a woman and [ __ ] look
like fortune findstr I got a bit full of
a side-by-side please tell me the same
fortune fine sister put it in the
podcast a flow yes
lovely little finger complete little
finger exploits everyone moves from
partisan a person like a [ __ ]
parasite mine and he will eventually get
his but can take a long time take a
while
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]